I have something really unfortunate to
talk about today it appears as though
YouTube may be generally messing with
independent news and politics channels
like the channel we have which now has
close to 700,000 subscribers now I can't
speak as broadly about this as I would
like to but I'll tell you what's going
on with our channel as a data point in
the last several months including with
the steven crowder carlos masa Fiasco
and for other reasons there have been
lots of people making allegations of
political bias within news and politics
at YouTube there are allegations that
YouTube is going after right-wing
channels specifically de prioritizing
them de monetizing them because they are
right-wing
there are others who say it's
left-wingers on YouTube that are
actually being hurt by changes to the
YouTube algorithm and my position has
basically been the same for a long time
now which is YouTube is prioritizing
what makes them money by keeping
advertisers happy there is a lot of
crazy right-wing content on YouTube
that's going to get caught up in that
that includes conspiracy stuff it
includes racist stuff it includes white
nationalist content and separatist
content and there's also some left-wing
stuff that's going to get caught in
there when left-wing channels talk about
ongoing conflicts whether they are in
Syria or Iraq or Saudi Arabia Yemen
whatever the case may be
there are algorithmic decisions that
YouTube is making that are going to
disproportionately hurt the left-wing
channels talking about those issues and
they will not hurt for example the
YouTube channels of corporate media
outlets that are talking about those
exact same issues and there have been
continued allegations through and
through that YouTube is specifically
going after one or the other side of the
political spectrum but what I'm here to
tell you today and I'm gonna back it up
with some data is that at minimum there
is an a political targeting not of left
or right wing content but of independent
content which is I believe being
deprioritized in lieu of corporate news
channels we are getting absolutely
crushed on YouTube as a result of the
algorithmic changes that have gone on
now I can't
say if this is because of one thing or
another what I can tell you is that this
predates the steven crowder Carlos Mazda
Fiasco it may have been exacerbated by
that but this is bigger than that and
it's really just genuinely bad for our
channel to make money on YouTube you
need views and the views need to be
monetized meaning it's not just views
but the views need to have ads play
before them in order for us to make
money now there are a bunch of different
ways that we get views on YouTube one
big way is called browse features browse
features include we have close to
700,000 subscribers on YouTube when
those people see our videos on their
homepage under their list of
subscriptions that is called a browse
feature view if someone views our
channel through something like that it's
mostly a function of subscribers the
more subscribers you have the more
Browse feature views you are going to
get there's another one which is called
suggested videos which are those videos
that YouTube suggests alongside on
desktop or below on mobile the video
that you are watching and this is a
hugely variable source of views and it
is dependent on YouTube's algorithmic
priorities our portion of views that
come from this suggested video feed has
declined by about 50%
back in September about 33% of our views
were coming from the suggested view
suggested features a sort of umbrella
that number has dropped from 33% to
under 17% and I'll explain to you why
this is such a big deal this is about
half of what we were once getting from
this algorithm and this decline started
right after YouTube announced that in an
effort to crack down on fake news it
will be doing more backing as they say
of what they call authoritative sources
and of course what might be a
well-intentioned good-faith effort to
crack down on fake news appears to be
absolutely crushing independent
producers
like us this decline from 33% to 17% of
our views coming from YouTube suggested
videos feed is a huge blow to our
revenue because it represents a ton of
views we had three and a half million
views in December not on the entire
channel just from the suggested video
feed okay in June we'll be lucky to get
one and a half million views from the
suggested video feed that's a two
million view shortfall okay that's a
huge revenue shortfall now I have to be
careful because my understanding is that
YouTube's Terms and Conditions say I
can't give you specific revenue numbers
so I'm not going to but losing two
million views because of changes to
YouTube's algorithm is a lot more money
than most people in the audience would
guess okay let me put it that way
and in the meantime although YouTube is
claiming that they're putting in place a
better more efficient system to make
sure the videos that are brand safe do
get ads playing on them look at what
happened yesterday we had a video from
yesterday get 90,000 views in the first
four hours a very this is in the top 1%
of our videos by getting 90,000 views
and in just the first four hours this
was a video about Donald Trump's
interview with George Stephanopoulos
where they talked about Donald Trump's
finances and the video was instantly
demonetised as you can see from the
yellow dollar sign on the screen
monetized videos have a green dollar
sign there is nothing not brand safe in
this video we appealed the decision were
told that those decisions should be
reviewed within an hour and it was not
reviewed for about 14 hours until such
time that the video had a hundred and
ten thousand views it has now been
romana ties but we lost the revenue on
one hundred and ten thousand views so
listen I have no control about over this
I have no control over any of what's
going on here channels like ours are
uniquely positioned to be the most
damaged from these algorithmic changes
and I'll explain what I mean by that the
big corporate news channel CNN whoever
they have huge ad revenue
outside of YouTube and YouTube is
favoring them anyway so they're fine
really small channels don't depend on
YouTube to fund ongoing multi employee
operations they're fine we who are in
the top one-and-a-half percent of
YouTube but not in the top point one
percent we are the people who will most
suffer so what can we do
I've said it before and I'll say it
again we've got two separate funding
from advertising that's it okay we have
direct support set up on our website
where we get 98% of every payment okay
we pay a two percent payment processing
fee ninety-eight percent of the
contributions through membership on our
website go directly to funding the show
we're looking at launching channels in
other languages with our content dubbed
in very high quality to reach people who
don't speak English we've started paying
for the subtitling and closed captioning
of our channel already we produce and
give the show to 200 non-commercial
radio and TV stations all of that stuff
costs money and under one percent of our
audience funds us directly through
membership right now if we can get to
two percent of our audience funding us
directly we laugh about these YouTube
issues we'll be in great shape if we can
get to three percent of our audience
funding us directly we would be
absolutely crushing it so this has to be
a wake-up call okay we've got to support
the shows that we value directly if we
can afford to do so if you can't that's
okay I'm still doing the show for you
okay I don't need your last dollar but
if you're used to buying one of those
lattes or two a month consider going to
WWJ pakman.com and saying I can afford
three bucks a month I can afford six
bucks a month the coupon code this is
2020 will save you 40% we're not talking
about a lot of money if you apply that
code to the $6 a month membership it's
three dollars and sixty cents a month
okay if you apply that coupon code to
the yearly membership it'll drop it from
$60 to just $36 let's make this happen
because this is this it's not any more
about this could happen
this is happening we have lost half of
our views on YouTube from the suggested
video feed and increasingly we
recommended the suggested videos our
corporate establishment legacy media
let's make this happen
okay I truly believe that our audience
is going to understand the importance of
this and I look forward to coming back
to you in a week and telling you how
inspired and flattered I am from the
audience support